Laisse-moi expliquer
[Musique]
ne voulons pas qu'il y ait du HID dans
ici, nous avons dû le déplacer de cet endroit
Nous quittons ici la ville de Sabang
Ne l'ai plus ici, s'il te plaît
nous tous en tant que communauté avec nos enfants
pourrait être préjudiciable à nos enfants
Nous lui avons également demandé de déménager immédiatement
de la ville de Sabang
Pour
c'est
Kun est isolé dans un camp mais ils
selon l'opinion de la société, il y a
certaines choses qui violent l'EE coutumière
douanes à Aceh, en particulier celles
à Sabang Bang, c'est le premier
deuxièmement à cause de l'ignorance du public
concernant les questions qui circulent actuellement
sur les réseaux sociaux Bang like us
je connais très bien les réseaux sociaux de nos jours
fort et les problèmes sont très faciles
[Musique]
[Taper]
propagé
[Musique]
[Taper]
Nous avons vu les nouvelles
il y a déjà du monde là-bas
La mafia c'est celui qui y entre
Ce type veut tuer ce qui est important pour lui
Obtenez cet argent, cette personne doit être poursuivie
alors tu dois être attrapé sinon
Ce
Sur Pulauondo il y a déjà un autre navire Del
se retourner pour rentrer
[Musique]
Aceh doit jour
nettoyer